hey everyone I'm back and just in time
to get to grips with nvidia's new
GeForce GTX 1080ti yes this is the one
we've been waiting for nvidia's worst
kept secret a consumer level version of
its epic Titan X Pascal now going into
this one I had several questions first
of all how has Nvidia cut down this card
so the $1,200 Titan can retain some kind
of value premium secondly does the TI
live up to the company's claims that it
can outperform its more expensive
counterpart and finally is it really 35%
faster than the existing GTX 1080 but
first up let's take a look at the card
itself and you can see that yes this
Founders addition is very much Cut From
the Same Cloth as nvidia's premium
Pascal products that are on the market
right now put the ti here side by side
with GTX 1080 and it looks pretty much
the same but there have been some
changes just like Titan X Pascal the 8
Pin power input at the top is
supplemented with a secondary six pin
socket effectively confirming that this
is a GPU with a 250 W TDP but perhaps
more surprising is that nvidia's
standard Port configuration on the rear
has been changed up the dual link DVI
port seen on every other top tier GPU
from Nvidia well that's gone now if one
interface did have to receive the chop
dual link DVI would be the one to get
rid of it's the only connection on the
rear here that cannot support 4K at 60
HZ anyway the good news is that removing
the port has allowed Nvidia to optimize
air flow for better Cooling in fact in
this regard The Firm reckons there's a
2X Improvement and that's pretty good
news as Titan X Pascal's overclocking
was very much limited by its thermals
and I can confirm that this is much
improved on the 1080ti here now
comparing the 1080ti to the Titan X
you'll need to dig a Little Deeper to
find any meaningful differences cuore
count is identical at
3,584 spread across 28 streaming
processors but Nvidia has tweaked base
and boost clocks to exceed the Titan's
Shader performance the big difference
though comes in memory configuration
bizarrely Nvidia has cut the Titan's 12
gigs of g5x memory down to well 11 it's
hardly a massive downgrade and it makes
you wonder what the point actually is
especially as it has an impact on other
areas of the card's design so for
example RS drop from 96 to 88 and a
384bit memory bus is reduced to 352bit
Instead This doesn't sound so good to me
to be honest memory bandwidth is crucial
at 4K resolution but Nvidia solution
here is to swap in new 11 GB per second
g5x modules so over overall bandwidth is
actually a minuscule improvement over
the Titans despite all of this meddling
but the bottom line is that with the
additional boost clocks in every way
that matters this card should be a
better performing product than the Titan
so let's take a look at Assassin's Creed
Unity performance here I like to include
this game in my benchmarks for a couple
of reasons even though it's so old first
of all its ultra high settings are a
massive workout for the GPU even 3 years
on from release and secondly Nvidia and
AMD don't really optimize for this title
specifically in newer drivers so it's
always good for measuring Baseline
performance and comparing to older
results and here we've got a 7.6% uplift
on TI at 4K though curiously there's no
change at all in our 1440p results but
the graph sort of highlights how much of
a muchness this all is moving over to
The Witcher 3 here both 1440p and 4K
gains a couple of FPS when moving to
1080 TI now across the Run of play again
it's sort of looking identical but the
slight boost Stacks up as the bench
plays out I mean it's not gamechanging
but optimizing for a 4K gameplay
experience typically involves battling
against your lowest frame rates so every
little helps I guess and for me the key
cell with the 1080ti is the fact that
this card will Propel you to 60 FPS at
4K even on some really demanding games
now of course you may need to tweak
settings and take some visual downgrades
many of which you may not even notice
but the 4K credentials of this card are
sound and we can demonstrate its
scalability beautifully right so let me
explain that I think we can all agree
that GTX 970 1060 rx480 are all great
cards for 1080p gaming so what if we
compare the 1080p results of that Trio
with the 4K results of the 1080ti now
with our Benchmark data that's exactly
what we can do and we get some
fascinating results let's start off with
Far Cry Primal the 1080 TI at 4K is a
touch slower than rx480 it lags behind
GTX 1060 but it's outperforming the 970
remember the new card is rendering four
times as many pixels and that's a
remarkable turnout minimum frame rate
here is 55 FPS so minimal tweaking from
the ultr level settings here should keep
us North of 60 and there's a similar
pattern with the division here the 1080
TI at 4K can't quite match the 1060 at
1080p but it's actually on level ground
with the rx480 the pattern continues
here with our demanding novigrad City
Benchmark from The Witcher 3 only the
1060 at 1080p beats the 1080 TI at 4K I
mean it's a remarkable turnout here and
if you've been keeping an eye on the
frame times you'll note that the 1080ti
isn't just delivering the raw frame
ratees delivering on fluidity to but
let's be completely upfront about this
not every every game will'll see this
exceptional level of scalability across
resolutions rise of the Tomb Raider at
its very high preset is a game that will
push any GPU to its limits the higher up
the resolution chain you go and compared
to the less capable cars running at
1080p it's significantly slower now this
title is actually one where it is really
difficult to get a solid 4K 60 log which
is perhaps not surprising when GTX 1060
at 1080p commands a 24% perform
performance lead over the 1080 TI at 4K
and older games releases conceived at a
time where 4K was just a crazy pipe
dream well the most demanding of those
may also cause issues as we check out
our Crisis 3 Benchmark there's a huge
gap between 1080 TI at 4K and 1060 at
full HD the cheaper card is actually
offering a 78% boost in frame rates but
in the meantime we can overclock it's
something I'd recommend with a third
party card rather than nvidia's as you
really need to ramp up the fans here to
keep things cool and this kicks up quite
a bit of noise but overall results from
overclocking aren't too shabby adding
170 MHz to the core should keep you at 2
GHz or in that general area and that's
something I could never achieve with
Titan X Pascal however the 11 GB per
second g5x on 1080ti doesn't have
anything like the same level of
overclocking head room as the slower
modules on the vanilla 1080 and the
Titan I could only add around 150 MHz
here and that's just a smidgen faster
than I could comfortably overclock the
RAM on the older cards and as you can
see this translates into an uplift in
the region of around 10% performance the
days of the insane Maxwell era
overclocks are well and truly gone but
with that said the notion of a chip of
this size hitting 2 GHz is pretty insane
it'll be interesting to see how third
party cards compare but typically
overclocking with Pascal has been
limited by the processor itself not its
thermals at the very least though the
custom coolers should be significantly
quieter than the reference card here so
there we go GTX 1080 TI it's a bit of a
monster but I feel it's really important
to point out the extent of this card's
power and how it should be deployed
let's go to The Witcher 3 here we're
comparing our benchmarks across 1080P
1440p and 2160p 4 if you like yes the
1080p result is pretty insane but note
how the frame rate line isn't consistent
and also note the stutter in frame times
What's Happening Here is that we are
actually hitting CPU limits even though
we're using an i7
6700k overclocked to 4.6 GHz but simply
there's a strong argument that this card
is simply too powerful if you're
planning to game at 1080p you're leaving
a lot of performance on the table by
doing that and note how relatively close
1080p and 1440p performance is here in
Hitman to the point where sometimes
performance actually hits exactly the
same level now this is a CPU intensive
game and although frame rates are
stupidly High clearly the GTX 1080 TI
should be performing better at 1080p
we're hitting the limits of our system
here even though we are running using
the dx12 API and yes Crisis 3 look this
game is approaching its fourth birthday
now but holy crap it can still monster a
modern i7 again again note how 1080p
performance varies so dramatically more
so than the 1440p and 4K readouts yes
that's what happens when you have a GPU
that's too powerful at lower resolutions
even when you have one of the fastest
gaming CPUs on the market right now The
Witcher 3 Crisis 3 Hitman they could all
hit CPU hard but even less challenging
titles like Far Cry Primal well check
this out note how the 1080P and 1440p
line here are intersecting again in this
area performance is limited by the
heavily overclocked i7 not the 1080 TI
bottom line we actually need more CPU
power at 1080p okay so that's all worth
bearing in mind then and it explains why
scalability over the vanilla GTX 1080
varies depending on your resolution
across eight tested games the GTX 1080
TI is 23% faster at 1080p 27% faster at
1440p and 30 1% faster at 4K really and
truly it's only really at 4K where CPU
is completely ruled out and we see the
full brutal power of the ti okay then so
this is the third GPU King Nvidia has
rolled out in less than a year and
alongside Titan X Pascal the performance
on offer here is absolutely phenomenal
and yes of course so is the price point
$700 us $700 UK that's a fat pile of
cash whichever way you slice it
obviously that is indeed a huge
reduction from the Titan's ludicrous
asking price but it's important to
understand that the capabilities of this
card will vary according to your system
primarily CPU and of course depending on
resolution but go in looking for the
best 4K GPU money can buy and you won't
be disappointed anyway I hope this was
useful yes I've been away and yes I will
be reviewing ryzen next so do look out
for that but in the meantime as always
please support digital Foundry whether
that's through liking subscribing or
supporting our patreon where you can
grab pristine download versions of all
of our videos but that's all I've got
for you for now thanks for watching